[Música]
[Aplausos]
vistas del cielo venecia parece casi
suspendida en el tiempo sin embargo al
borde del agua la vida la ciudad retoma
seis meses después de la explosión del
coronavirus en italia en el gran canal
los gondoleros vuelven a remar los
visitantes reaparecen poco a poco y
descubren una ciudad transformada aquí
es tranquilo agradable estuve aquí hace
años y había mucha más gente
antes para caminar teníamos que pegarnos
a la gente así ahora hay claramente
menos turistas menos turistas menos
turistas y por una buena razón desde la
crisis del coronavirus los visitantes
estadounidenses y asiáticos han
desaparecido dejando los italianos
redescubrir las bellezas de la ciudad
antes solíamos veranear cada año fuera
de italia pero este año preferimos no
volar fuimos a las montañas del norte y
pensamos aprovechar la oportunidad de
visitar venecia
notas de música para alegrar el ambiente
y dar una apariencia de vida normal en
la plaza de san marcos uno de los
lugares más emblemáticos de la ciudad
pero para algunos aquí falta algo
treyarch no es extraño no hay mucha
gente está un poco sin vida y es triste
ver las tiendas cerradas
jobs a close una situación visible en
varias zonas de la ciudad
tiendas clausuradas restaurantes parados
y hoteles con las persianas cerradas y
para quienes han retomado la actividad
la situación es en todo caso complicada
cuesta una draga esta es una de nuestras
habitaciones más bonitas con vistas al
gran canal por el momento se vende a un
cuarto de su precio normal y por otro
porque la gente ya no viene aquí y eso
nos obliga a bajar los precios otras
destinaciones en un samu con tres
tiendas bazar el precio de la cámara no
te ball mente
por falta de clientes de fania tuvo que
poner a sus 15 empleados en desempleo
parcial estima que ya ha perdido el 70%
de su facturación anual por trapo no
imán que tú todo lindo inglés ya hemos
perdido a todos nuestros clientes
ingleses estadounidenses y rusas que son
los que más tienen poder adquisitivo y
gastan en hoteles restaurantes y tiendas
no sabemos si sobreviviremos si la
situación no mejora podríamos hablar
definición en noviembre emitida parte de
ella sobrevive no ya pensamos a
noviembre de cólera
una situación que afecta a todo el
archipiélago de la laguna de venecia que
cuenta con más de un centenar de islas
entre las cuales la isla de murano
conocida por la tradición de la
artesanía de vidrio conocida en el mundo
entero
nicole en su hermano alberto son
artesanos desde hace más de 30 años
trabajan con vidrio en todas sus formas
y colores los hornos están apagados
porque no tenemos más pedidos desde el
inicio del confinamiento unos hornos de
vidrio del taller han cesado de
funcionar y todavía siguen apagados y
formes unos 20 y por quien una pena mora
boro
no pretendemos ser millonarios sólo
queremos poder trabajar en paz
lo que da miedo es que ya no somos
jóvenes nunca habríamos pensado nuestra
edad que nos encontraríamos en esta
situación arriba ya hemos pensado varias
veces en dejarlo todo y cerrar
y simular el tutor y formarse en 30 años
el número de talleres de vidrio en
murano se ha dividido por 10 una
tradición amenazada si la crisis del
cobi 19 se prolonga
antes de coronavirus venecia y su laguna
atraían a unos 30 millones de turistas
al año la pérdida repentina esta entrada
económica afecta considerablemente las
finanzas de la ciudad se estima que para
finales de año las arcas públicas de
venecia perderán 100 millones de euros y
una pérdida significativa porque ese
dinero financiaba servicios importantes
servicios de los que carecen los
habitantes de venecia
muchos de ellos no ocultan su
insatisfacción
todas las actividades que nos sirven
están cerrando y se convierten en
tiendas turísticas benítez apuntando
sólo futurismo en una punta
venecia lo apostó todo a los turistas
sino a su gente y hoy vemos lo que pasa
así que ahora tenemos que dar un paso
atrás pensar primero en la gente y
repensar las prioridades de venecia el
veneciano generar y vender están te
conoces viven en estas se con tomates
hoy en día venecia cuenta con unos 50
mil habitantes tres veces menos que hace
50 años mientras que el número de
turistas no deja de aumentar un fenómeno
que denuncia este grupo de activistas
con un chip o víveres tenemos que dejar
de vivir solo el turismo
hay que reconstruir el tejido social
para que la gente trabaje y viva en
venecia porque en este momento la gente
está trabajando en venecia y por las
noches se van laboran avena etsiam
apoyarían entran o si estás la ciudad
está perdiendo a sus habitantes cuando
no haya más venecianos en venecia una
civilización milenaria desaparecerá una
civilización que siempre ha convivido
con el frágil ecosistema de esta laguna
marcos gaspar y net y es abogado
especializado en causas ambientales
durante 20 años gestionó los archivos
relacionados con la laguna de venecia en
la comisión europea en bruselas
la laguna es único sistema transitorio y
frágil sin la mano del hombre para
preservarla
está destinada a desaparecer debemos
tener la capacidad de entender que si no
cambiamos de rumbo no quedará nada para
nuestros hijos ni para las generaciones
futuras
[Música]
cambiar radicalmente o desaparecer este
es el dilema al que se enfrenta esta
ciudad clasificada como patrimonio
mundial de la humanidad
[Música]